so Michael I people who know me movie
music better than I say there's at least
over two dozen composers who've worked
on Star Trek series and movies and
things including Jerry Goldsmith and
James Horner and water Rosenman the
first film was much more of a problem
for me then this one was the first one
in trying to you know I grew up unlike
Brian I watched the old series i love
the old series and it was you know I had
the action figures i have the the
Enterprise bridge playset diced you know
all that when you spin the thing I don't
know if anyone remembers this has as if
it's past him I still have it axles I
actually do they're all in my office
along with my plan of the Apes toys so
but so so coming to it I had all of this
baggage of everything I grew up with
everything I love I listen to all those
scores growing up you know James
Horner's music Jerry Goldsmith's you
know Alexander carriage all of those
guys are heroes to me and I love that
stuff so I kept writing in the beginning
writing you know okay what's going to be
our theme what's going to be our theme
and I was writing all this music that
sounded like space music you know and
and none of it fit what we were doing
but I kept trying to bright space music
it's got to be this style of thing
because this is what you do with Star
Trek we would always listen to it night
and never it just wasn't working do you
remember this numbers had been about 25
versions of this thing you know that and
finally I was having a conversation it
was really sort of like depressed about
it and I was talking to Damon Lindelof
and he said well how about this look at
it this way he goes forget the fact that
we're making a movie about space forget
that the enterprise forget Kirk and
Spock let's just do a movie about two
guys who meet and become friends right
that moment right that theme right and I
was like oh that's actually really smart
and Damon was the one who said no no he
smacked me you know like those old 40s
movies where the detective grabs the
woman and smacks the girl back and forth
that's what he did to me and and then I
wrote this next name and that's the one
that JJ was like that's our theme that's
that's the one that belongs so when I
came to this movie already felt like I
had built a home and it was just about
then adding an addition onto the home
and coming up with new ideas and new
themes and taking the old theme and that
had done in twisting it in new ways and
it was more about just you know I could
have fun with it at this point and
create new ideas already knowing that
the house was built the last film was
interesting because everybody was kind
of doing it for the first time and it
was it was a little bit like god I hope
the Star Trek fans aren't going to kill
us I hope you know Chris was like I'm
going to be walking around wearing
spandex and like is that going to work
out and there was a lot of like we
didn't know what we were getting
ourselves into we hoped it would work
and we were fortunate to have a good
reaction on the last film so doing this
one it was a little bit less I wonder if
this is going to work and we were able
to really focus on on expanding the
universe and not having to reset it in
the same way we did on the last film and
there was a general kind of joy
throughout the whole thing Pleasant
which is a weird thing which is JJ's
only condition to directing this film
was to directed in Los Angeles and where
did you record here in LA as always you
know it's equally rare as much as I can
do I've been one of the few people in
town that's been so fortunate that every
single thing I've done so far has been
recorded here you know if I had my way I
would do it like that forever i love it
i love the musicians here that they're
the best in the world i will go down to
the set i love going visiting the set i
love being on set and watching JJ work
what I love about JJ is that he will he
loves practical effects you know if you
can do an in camera effect he wants to
try it he loves that that fascinates him
he you know we're but were all huge fans
of like old films and and the way they
used to do things and how would they
accomplish these things just with when
they didn't have computers so you know
in that shot where they're running down
the hallway where Scotty and Kirk are
running down the hallway and the whole
thing is spinning you know normally you
would put that thing on the giant gimbal
and and and twisted the whole set and
deal with that well JJ was like well why
don't we just turn the camera and put
them on a wire so that they're kind of
running sideways and it's holding them
and we're just turning the camera and it
worked beautifully I mean it looked
amazing and I remember just thinking
that is the most awesome thing I would
have I've ever seen because i feel like
it took me right back to being 12 years
old making super 8 movies going and
that's the kind of stuff you had to do i
couldn't build a giant set that would so
you turn the cam
it's as simple as that it's little
things like that that you know and if he
had to do that digitally or visual
effects it would have cost a fortune I
had to make sure it was a film that
really appealed to I would often
reference my mother and to make sure
that she understood what was going on
when we used to we did alias together
that's where Michael and I started
working together and I have a very
wonderful stereotypical Jewish mother
who would watch religiously all of our
alias episodes and I would know if it
was a good episode or a bad episode
because it was good she would say she'd
leave a message and like honey tonight's
episode was so great and she'd start
talking about Sydney Bristow and she
talked about the episode or i would get
honey tonight's episode was so cool with
no description and which meant she
didn't understand what was going on and
so while we're making these films you
want to make sure that everybody
understands it and it's not overly Star
Trek heavy so that I could I wouldn't be
able to enjoy